on va parler du texte les députés
socialistes devraient s'abstenir demain
sur la loi séparatisme main pour aller
vite
est-ce que ça serait la position de
votre groupe au sénat il est fort
probable que nous votons contre ce texte
quand les plus loin que les députés pour
quelles raisons pour une simple raison
c'est que je crains les apports qui vont
être apportées par la droite sénatoriale
je pensais qu'il y avait une lecture
très politique de ce texte par la droite
sénatoriale aux as déjà les dégainer
voilà sur le sujet intégration de la
question du voile fin je pense qu'on va
avoir une caricature de ce texte qui
comporte des choses positives sur le
financement des cultes sur la lutte
contre les trafics à de virginité sur le
lit contre la polygamie
il ya des choses positives dans ce texte
qui peut être ai je l'espère vont
subsister mais la droite sénatoriale va
encore une fois qu'un cas tu rêves à la
grave et potentiellement dans un
objectif qui est aussi celui de la
perspective de la candidature de
monsieur retailleau donc il ya des
chances que nous votions canton
fiançailles en mai mais en l'état si le
texte était resté le même
au sénat nous verrons bien au mois de
mars à fin avril
nous sommes juste un mot sur l'article
18 l'article sur la haine en ligne qui
condamne la mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui par diffusion d'informations
malveillantes
cet article lu ya eu pas mal de
discussions à ce sujet est-ce que celui
là vous le voteriez en l'état
c'est en tout cas ces îles il répond
plus aux préoccupations que la fameuse
loi avia que nous avons combattu compris
sur un plan que l'article 24 de la salle
comont donc le débat va avoir lieu
permettez moi de prendre un peu de recul
par rapport à l'excution que j'aurai
dans avec mon groupe politique encore
une fois je les dis il ya des choses qui
vont dans le bon sens qui porte qui
pourront être améliorées simplement il
vient à manquer qui est majeure dans ce
texte c'est qu'il est essentiellement
régalien autoritaire répressif dans
beaucoup de cas et qu'il n'y a pas de
préoccupation sur lequel on évoquait en
effet tout à l'heure sur voile à
l'équilibré social qui cité la laïcité
ces prises aussi viendra sociale
[Musique]